vous êtes à jour à londres c'est pour ma
femme je vous adore
bonjour j'arrête à la piscine ou la
lâche et au world allait ouvrir et vous
ressemblez à gerland en plus petits
n'ont
pas compris que c'est possible de venir
sur un tournage à hong kong mais pas
demain parce que c'est mon premier jour
j'aimerais être tranquille il ya sept
personnes qui sont dans la loge et qui
vous demande
[Musique]
mais en fait je leur avais déjà dit oui
à vous nous disiez non c'est fou ce qui
vous en faire le nez franchement c'est
le plus impressionnant
[Musique]
le nez c'est bien il est super le nez
gérard
attention maintenant la discrétion
car la discrétion c'est nous
[Musique]
tu sais quoi
j'ai attendu un on dirait un vieux chien
en
tout cas de gale ont conclu que les
boulettes oui voilà ça fait quoi trois
jours qu'on se connaît j'ai l'impression
que ça fait vingt piges qu'on vit
ensemble à paris c'est dingue c'est fou
comme ça c'est quoi ça c'est une panne
d'essence comment vais je m'en vais
c'est pas le moment de ma vie entière ne
suis jamais arrivé en retard par rapport
à votre rôle entre pas que des bonnes
choses moi je vais tout à fait honnête
avec vous là en face de moi l'un des
pages armes j'ai un gérard sûrement mais
c'est pas le gérard lanvin
make up 1 c'est à dire on se réveille
alors maquillage maquille pas qui